talk to me about pension funds and large
capital allocators it seems like they're
really screwed right they've for years
and years and years now applied kind of
a 60 40 type portfolio a lot of it is
kind of cover your asset worse i don't
want to have any sort of career risk so
if i just do what everyone else is doing
then i can't get fired and that has been
okay right most of them are hitting
somewhere between you know five to seven
percent their actuarial rate of return
is usually somewhere seven and a half
eight percent but they're missing the
mark uh we just saw calpers uh which is
one of the largest pension funds in the
country decided they're going to now
start taking on leverage they're going
to start adding more uh alternative
assets like you just start seeing some
of this stuff and i don't think they
even think that they're necessarily uh
becoming more conservative or better
investors they're just saying like we
have no choice we have to do this or
literally we can't pay people like how
do you read that first of all i want to
say max pretty much got kicked off stage
in uh what was it 2005 or six when uh he
was on stage with one of the heads of
calpers at the time it was at 2000. they
let you close yeah yeah
it was at the triple bottom line
investing conference and um they it was
just announced it was like in um march
or april of maybe 2007 or something like
that
2006 and they had just announced that
they bought all these cdos the headlines
look it up from bear stearns and max
said you know why these things are going
to zero so uh and why are you putting
this in these uh your pension funds for
these uh teachers and me you know
government workers in in um in
california and uh they they refused to
have their you know there was a group
photo afterward and they were like we
can't have max in there but of course
of course bear stearns blew up soon
after that max said it was going to zero
so
but i think one one quick thing is that
uh in terms of the pension stuff i think
it's that's kind of intergenerational
because uh no millennials or zoomers
have pensions right it's just the
boomers and the boomers are trying to
reconcile with reality and the reality
is that they've incurred a huge amount
of debt they blew the legacy that was
america they blew this giant
amazing economy and turned it into trash
exported all our jobs left a hollow out
shell of rust belt and a hundred
thousand annual overdose deaths so
they're the ones that created that and i
think you know fortunately for zoomers
and millennials
they've got bitcoin
yeah yeah and you know the pension funds
you're talking they're getting five to
seven percent but how far out on the
risk curve are they going for that
they're going way out on the risk curve
you know ten-year treasuries are one and
a half percent
so they're they're taking on an enormous
amount of risk and they're they're
exposed to an enormous amount of risk
and they're going to lose an enormous
amount of money um and that's pretty
clear the um
what's really sad about the whole
pension industry and about the savings
industry is that
the
uh artificial suppression of interest
rates you know the past 10 15 20 years
has effectively moved five trillion
dollars from pension accounts and
savings accounts
into the pockets of speculators it's a
theft right the interest rate should
have been allowed to increase long ago
they normalized rates you know if you
look at different schools of thought and
different studies you know you come up
with around five percent would be a
normalized
rate and we kind of fluctuate around
five percent so we've been hovering
around zero for years now uh even and
even though you've got uh all kinds of
indications of bubbles forming in
everywhere that would require a response
from the central bank to raise rates
instead they've lowered rates
and
they've effectively stolen a lot of
money from these pension accounts they
go into the speculators pockets and then
speculators end up getting more
political power and then they end up
influencing washington to pass laws to
make it easier for them to take money
out of pension accounts you know this is
something el salvador is going to have a
chance to avoid because they're now
going to be writing securities laws and
rewriting securities laws for the first
time in el salvador and they're going to
do so in ways that have go to school
onto problems in the u.s and what's
happened and to avoid all that and based
on built on a bitcoin standard so all
that kind of um influence peddling
market manipulation and this the top you
know the market you know you've watched
our show you know my show you know us
we've been reporting on this
not only on on the kaiser report but
going back 18 19 years
the amount of manipulation by these
banks and bankers is is ludicrously off
the chart i mean jamie dimon i'm not
going to go on a huge tangent there but
they paid hundreds of millions of
dollars in fines they were caught
rigging precious metals markets the bank
of england caught rigging libor market
every single market maker and bank
around the world has been caught
manipulating markets stealing money
front-running markets congress is even
trading on inside information the level
of corruption is extraordinary and it's
all fueled by that ultra cheap money
that's why they don't want to raise
rates you don't think nancy pelosi wants
higher rates if she's able to stick her
sticky little fingers in the pie every
day and take some cash out based on
insider trading and artificially cheap
credit that's not where it's going to
come from so they're incentivized to
commit fraud if you took fraud out of
the u.s business model you'd have
nothing